من الواضح أن الحكومة الإسرائيلية قلقة للغاية
من احتمال حدوث ذلك في الواقع ، فأنا الآن
أسمع صفارات الإنذار
للصواريخ القادمة وبالطبع الآن
الجنود هنا
يختبئون وإذا استدرنا هنا يمكنني أن
أريكم أن أه الفلسطينيين في  الأم
التي أمام المسجد
تهتف وتصرخ الله أكبر حتى تتمكن من رؤية
انقسام كبير جدًا بين اليهود الإسرائيليين
والإسرائيليين الفلسطينيين
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالوضع هنا في
الواقع ، شخص ما أطلق
الألعاب النارية وأعتقد أنه
يمكنك القول  ابتهج على هذه
الصواريخ ، ما هذا الذي
يحمله هناك يمكنني رؤيته ،
حسنًا ، حسنًا ، أرى بعض
الصواريخ
تم
اعتراضها من قبل ما يسمى بنظام القبة الحديدية ،
وقد نرغب في الانتقال إلى موقع أفضل
فقط في حالة سقوط شيء ما من
السماء وسمعت إطلاق نار أيضًا
يبدو أنه إطلاق نار
احتفالي من ذلك  أنا من السكان العرب في
هذه البلدة
أيضًا كشكل من أشكال
الاحتفال بالصواريخ التي يتم إطلاقها ، إنها لعبة
نارية سمعتها للتو.